je te l'avais si tu me rencontrer
[Musique]
dans quel sens dans le sens sexuel
sexuellement par le nom et pas assez
musclé est ce qu'au delà d'une mode tap
a inventé une tête une tête de turc oui
peut-être pour certaines personnes
tu crois que tu es un créateur de génie
où l'apôtre du mauvais goût
bon plus facilement je dirais peut-être
impôts du mauvais goût marquant je sais
pas très bien ce que c'est que le
mauvais goût et bon vivant
créateur de génie là je dois dire que je
crois pas je crois pas qu'ils aillent de
génie ok beaucoup de travail surtout ça
très fatigué d'ailleurs pas ce travail
non j'aime toujours autant mais enfin ça
me fatigue physiquement donc créateur de
génie c'est parce que c'est non plus
vraiment à création est-ce que tu ne
serait pas le premier couturier de l'ère
de la télévision je sais pas si je suis
le premier mais en tous les cas c'est
sûr que je ne suis pas que je le suis en
tous les cas de l'ère de la télévision
si je dois dire depuis que je suis gamin
je regarde la télé tout le temps tout le
temps tout temps et encore maintenant je
la regarde tout le temps et je crois que
c'est la télévision en fin de compte qui
n'a et les médias qui m'a appris le
métier j'ai pas fait d'école c'est la
télé c'est à dire qu'en fin de compte
les émissions d'avertis dim dam dom
aussi qui m'ont appris en fin de compte
ce que je fais tu ne penses pas que dans
les années 80 on a un peu trop divinisé
le chiffon tout est à chaque fois tout
est exagéré dans tous les sens dans les
années 70 par contre il était
complètement renier alors qu'en fin de
compte y ait des gens qui prétendaient
ne pas être à la mode ni suivre la mode
alors qu'en fin de compte ils étaient
les archétypes même de la mode des
années 70 c'est à dire le côté look
jeans avec le cheveu long comme ça et
genre je m'en fous je suis en dehors de
la mode et je la relis bon donc c'était
en fin de compte il était très à la mode
quand même
maintenant on dit la mode partout on dit
que les créateurs sont des rock stars
presque même quand ils font pas de
disque et bien tu as combien de fashion
victim sur la conscience les fashion
victimes à la fois je les aime bien et
ça m'effraie un petit peu aussi bon je
les aime bien pourquoi parce que ça
prouve en fin de compte une espèce car
ça peut être parce que l aime beaucoup
ce que je fais dans ces cas là c'est
flatteur j'aime bien évidemment parcours
aussi la fashion victim c'est simplement
parce que un nom qu'on doit porter à
tout prix
qu'on doit porter à tout prix parce que
c'est le moment de le porter et tous
âges des têtes c'est arrive souvent de
porter une de tes jupe pour homme oui je
suis tombé deux fois dans un escalier
d'ailleurs je suis pris les pieds dedans
après j'ai essayé la chape ce bon ben la
chape ce site vous combien d ouverture
c'est un petit peu plus facile
donc là j'ai même pu danser avec enfin
la jupe pour homme je l'avais pas fait
au départ en pensant que le monde entier
que tous les gens dans la rue portrait
la jupe pour homme j'avais fait surtout
bombardé d'une part parce que c'était
une envie qui correspondait à un peu à
certaines personnes que je voyais et
puis à moi aussi à apporter d'avoir été
très masculine pour elle et qu'elle
portait avec un costume avec une cravate
ou il ya un trois-pièces carrément et
mais en fin de compte si tu es surtout
parce que symbolisait en fin de compte
le fait qu'il ya plein de garçons qui
voulaient est habillé de façon un petit
peu différente et pas seulement avec des
des petits costumes étriqués pour quel
genre vient d'ailleurs dans madame la
collection tu fais 20 milliards de
centimes de chiffre d'affaires tu fais
quoi tout ce pognon et écoute alors
absolument rien c'est ça qui est
dramatique c'est je n'ai aucune
imagination pour les dépenser alors
c'est pas moi qu'il se dépense
je vais pas dire que j'ai des espèce de
sangsue et alentours de moi non c'est
pas ça non je crois que tout cet argent
là va comment
tu entends des projets dans des choses
comme ça si tu veux mais seul luxe en
vérité parce que j'ai pas de besoin je
pourrais dans une chambre de bonne ce
que j'ai toujours et c'est tout à fait
vrai c'est pas que je veux dire mon dieu
c'est un impôt parce que je trouve pas
cette vertu du tout j'aime bien des gens
qui dépensent tout ça vient aussi après
tout l'argent on a fait toujours ici une
espèce de complexe d'avoir de l'argent
ou dépenser de l'argent ou saab est en
fin de compte le choc après tout
l'attitude des américains et dans un
sens beaucoup plus honnête que que la
nôtre bon donc j'ai pas du tout ce
complexe là ce qu'il ya c'est que j'ai
pas envie quand on me demande même comme
cadeau qu'est ce que je voudrais c'est
pas que j'ai tout pas du tout mais j'ai
pas vraiment d'environ 20 contre ma plus
grande envie c'est de faire ce métier je
le fais tu prépares quoi pour le
prochain film de peter greenaway avec
richard bohringer et ben je prépare tous
les costumes et c'est un sacré boulot
un sacré boulot pourquoi parce que
monsieur greenway à une idée géniale
génial génial génial c'est de bon chaque
pièce il ya une cuisine ça se passe dans
une cuisine une salle de restaurant un
jardin à une autre pièce encore des
quatre pièces chaque fois une couleur
différente et toutes les personnes du
film à chaque fois qu'ils passent dans
la pièce prennent la couleur de la pièce
sur leurs vêtements c&a qui viennent
tout blanc quand ils sont dans la
cuisine tout rouge quand ils sont dans
la salle de restaurant ce qui veut dire
que tous les vêtements doivent être
multipliés par quatre tu as déclaré que
tu était saturé par la récupération des
grandes causes par le showbiz c'est bien
leur opportunisme aussi parce que la
mode c'est aussi l'opportunisme je vous
dis quelquefois quand c'est vraiment une
espèce d'évidence que maintenant il faut
trouver ça bien et maintenant il faut
s'intéresser à cela je préfère les gens
en fin de compte qui s'intéresse depuis
un moment qu'ils découvrent pas vingt
ans après tout le monde
un blouson cuir avec un tutu c'est déjà
du sampling tu as suivi la même démarche
pour ton disque exactement t'as tout
compris
c'est tout à fait ça c'est à dire que
bonjour je faisais les bandes sons de
de mes défilés en coupant comme ça et en
prenant l'introduction d'un morceau et
tous étaient un petit peu un vol en fin
de compte et mélangeant quelquefois avec
même des bandes sons de films et puis
voilà et puis dans mes shows ça toujours
été un petit peu quand même comme des
comme des spectacles
ça te fait quoi de savoir que ton 10
marchera beaucoup moins bien que tes
vêtements d'abord suis pas sûr que ça va
moins bien
or jean paul gaultier bonsoir lors
gauthier sa vie son oeuvre du public et
mémoire ça y est sous forme de roman
photo
ça s'appelle à nous de la mode et ça
s'est passé comment c'est quoi la génèse
de cette affaire
[Musique]
bah ce qui s'est passé c'est que bon on
m'avait déjà proposé plusieurs fois de
faire un livre d'écrire un livre
et puis enfin comment je me sens pas du
tout capable d'écrire et depuis je suis
même pas capable d'écrire une carte
postale
j'ai du mal j'ai beaucoup mal j'hésite
et tout ça prend trop de temps alors du
coup je le fais pas non les limites les
croix c'est ce que je peux faire je
crois
on a eu un coup de fil après je crois de
françoise verny 10 ans justement qu'elle
voulait faire un livre ou que j'écrive
un livre je vais dire impossible alors y
avait la ressource bien sûr du du make
way que je n'apprécie pas tellement
parce qu'en fin de compte pour c'est un
peu mentir quoi alors donc bon ben là la
seule chose dont j'ai réfléchi je me
suis dit non c'est pas possible je vais
pas envie non plus un livre avec oui
parce que pour moi la mode c'est quoi
parce que c'était parler de la mode
évidemment la mode c'est des images
avant tout la rue je suis un enfant des
images j'aime la télé j'aime le cinéma
je ne lis pas alors que les gens en
lisant un livre s'ennuie comme moi je
pourrais m'ennuyer ans dans dix ans 1
j'avais pas tellement envie donc je vais
montrer des images r je me suis dit le
roman photo de toi qu'on sait très bien
alors scénarios patrick rambaud oui
conseillère monique pivot est une
spécialiste des éditions mondiales qui
fait tousser journal à la perfection un
soin vaut pas cher en plus c'est rigolo
ouais 95 francs cela oui et non alors il
ya aujourd'hui sans couleurs je discute
avec jean teulé de copains de bernard
rapp et puis après tout les flash back
en noir et blanc alors il ya la vocation
le voilà qui est on nous tue mais qui
est vraiment en hausse alors c'est vrai
hein j'ai encore l'ours qui est là et
tout c'est un petit monstre parce que je
lui faisais soubie subir un petit peu
tout ce qui se passait à l'époque c'est
à dire que c'était l'époque où il y
avait une opération à coeur ouvert
professeur barnard gelot pérenne alors
pas à coeur ouvert un petit peu là au
milieu là est fait avec des épingles je
refusais y avait le mariage de favols
abiola et de du roi baudouin paraissent
mariait voilà alors il ya des foules et
et fabiola il ya d'autres fois il est
tout dépend d'elle de l'humeur alors on
voit tam et mes cheveux bleus des
couleurs et puis alors ton père dont il
n'a pas le beau rôle à ben non ohlala
mais là je mettais mes parents il faut
jamais quand même été très riche en
abondance que l'avait demandé en péril
air sévère quand même bah oui c'est
parce que sa version italienne de mon
père j'ai des traits culturels évalue
macho il ya un truc très rigolo ça me
fait penser à la pub de guy degrenne tu
sais à un moment tu es en classe et puis
on shoppe en train de dessiner des pépés
infâme avec des corses et des trucs ne
ferai jamais rien donc monsieur guy
degrenne s'est exactement passé un petit
peu ça ouais je crois que il ya pas mal
de guy degrenne non dans plein de
domaines en fin de compte et ça c'est à
dire que je dessinais comme moi je
regardais tout le temps la télé ma grand
mère quand même quel génial me laissait
voir tout la télévision avec les choses
qui avait le rectangle blanc j'ai tout
kindle damien ce dim dam dom au saas et
c'était plus tard ça c'est vraiment
c'est la bible reste qu'un pour moi bon
il y avait aussi avec l'amérique sur le
temps y avait sauté sur wii
aussi le théâtre de la jeunesse était
très bien sans télé santana général ça
c'était vraiment très bien et je
regardais tous et je regardais aussi
même des films qui étaient interdits et
notamment une émission sur je crois la
dernière revue des folies bergère est
donc là j'avais vu toutes ces femmes en
plus mais avec des bas résilles j'avais
redessiné ça le lendemain à l'école
bon et puis ils savaient pas tellement
plus quoi lassitude crise alors du coup
je vais faire tout le tour pour montrer
le dessin que j'avais fait mais moi
j'étais fier bon alors on te souhaite
beaucoup de succès avec ce bouquin plus
qu'avec ton disque mais méritée 1 à
succès comme ça j'ai quand même vendu 42
c'est vrai oui et j'ai été 52e presque
par des contres top 5 en voilà un petit
peu
vraiment il a fait une semaine de l'été
la sadc johnny dira tout même la ville a
acheté alors dans ton roman photo à la
fin on voit tout et amie rita mitsouko
yvette horner on voit freiné avec leur
cas mais l'ampleur du travail avec toi
et 7 yvette horner tu l'a relooké
complètement tu vas tu l'a complètement
revampé faut bien le dire maintenant
c'est madonna alors là changement de
changement de taille pas bah oui oui le
premier point commun c'est d'abord que
je suis un fan aussi bien d'yvette
horner que de madonna c'est elle qui a
appelé ses abrite six celui et puis
après il m'a donné le numéro pour que je
les rejoigne et puis alors je dirai
simplement parce que j'étais au bord de
l'apoplexie évidemment quand j'ai vu sa
voix en plus c'est génial parce que
c'est à dire est taiwan tous pictet cie
ce matin
avec son accent les hypers rigolote
c'est quand même vraiment bien
alors après tu es allé la voir à new
york voilà et puis ça c'est vrai qu'elle
a un frère avait quelques est un peu à
madonna ce qu'orlando était à dalida
c'est à dire la protège un peu il la
protège il est là il lui donne quelques
avis comme ça quelques touches mais elle
elle fait ce qu'elle veut enfin je veux
dire quand même c'est assez étonnant
parce que c'est elle allait absolument
pas diriger c'est elle qui décide qui
disent ça va ça va pas jouer ça c'était
qui est produit par exemple son prochain
tour et bombe à son frère il est là pour
lui donner quelques par exemple à un
moment j'avais proposé mois parmi tous
les contenus proposés comme une pré
vierge madone et où je pensais un moment
qu'elle pourrait aller sous une douche
et puis du roller enfin que sa nudité se
révèle comme ça par le vêtement
transparent et tout ça ça me plaisait
beaucoup mais le frère lui il était oui
regardez même avec avec la religion avec
l'équipe rayonne quelques petits
problèmes de fer de lance comme sandrine
de pepsi ou trois paraît-il à nouveau
sera fait
donc ouais non non pas du tout qu'est-ce
qu'elle discutait faut nuancer l2 et l1
c'est assez incroyable c'est une vraie
business woman quoi elle est dure en
affaire al hemali navigant même je dis
une chose c'est que quand je les fais je
me suis dit tant pis si je gagne rien là
dessus ça me plaît et tout beau il ya
des tas de choses que j'aurais pu gagner
vraiment mal et à la foire jean-paul oui
oui nation après les venues en france te
voir et à les mener à noël juste aux
fêtes de fin d'année et a passé le
réveillon avec elle voilà et warren
beatty étaient pas là il n'était pas là
et quand même quand tu es allé faire les
essayages elle avait perdu 6 kilos bah
voila si ça c'est bien que apple parce
qu'elle faisait tout l'entraînement et
tout ce qu'il ya de génial quand même c
est incroyable c'est qu'elle s'entraîne
tous les jours
bon ça c'était la préparation aussi de
son choix je crois que dans sa vie de
tous les jours elle est hyper tu vois
genre elle se fout de large et arrière
et me macrobiotique même de l'eau sont
pas un martini temps en temps et mégane
taille écoute j'ai pas les mesures en
tête que je peux te dire qu'elle a une
petite taille qu'elle est
merveilleusement pour 1,36 je dirais
parfaitement portionné mais pas grand
dam à 65,65 avec des belles s'écoule une
belle poitrine ont parfaitement à c'est
un petit bijou elle te plaît à les
superbes alors elle vient à paris là au
mois de juillet girouard tous les
penseurs
quitterai mais est il n'était pas jean
paul gaultier bah je sais pas en fin de
compte j'ai pas non j'ai pas vraiment de
héros comme ça enfin josé pour les jours
le
jean paul gaultier merci d'être avec
nous merci d'être avec nous puisque
demain c'est la collection homme et vous
êtes ici malgré tout malgré tes adieux
malgré les larmes de catherine les
champs de laetitia et jean paul gaultier
vous remarquerez le m messieurs a eu la
délicatesse de s'habiller en thierry
ardisson c'est vrai ça c'est sympa merci
après
demande de vous arrêter après ça fait un
peu mégalo quand même jean paul bonsoir
en tous les cas rang merci d'être là
semaine cruciale effectivement pour la
mode avec l'art est effectivement de la
maison saint laurent semaine des défilés
dans le vôtre que j'ai eu la chance de
voir dimanche dernier alors pierre bergé
a dit en parlant de vous c'est le plus
grand depuis saint laurent et on a
longtemps cru d'ailleurs que vous seriez
le successeur d'yves saint laurent mais
maintenant vous et votre petite affaire
à vous voilà revenu à un petit chez soi
quand j'ai un projet de taille gueule
que jean-paul ya encore 65% de sa maison
donc celui qui décide 35% chez hermès
c'est parfait vous êtes bien démerdé
alors vous étiez au dernier défilé de
saint laurent mais bourse dé rendre
hommage ce maître yves saint laurent et
il y avait quand même ce qui est
incroyable ça c'est très très typique de
l'exception française
il y avait des grands écrans dehors et
puis des gens mille personnes qui ont
applaudi à la fin du défilé jusqu'à
l'incroyable salon c'est génial on va
faire partager à des tas de gens qui
n'étaient pas dans la salle ça s'est
très très bien
ouais et c'est rare en plus en plus cité
un moment quand même exceptionnel quoi
de voir une rétrospective comme ça de
vêtements qui ont datait de 1960
j'ai pas un navet en 61,3 la prochaine
collection pratiquement alors karl
lagerfeld a déclaré dimanche dans le
journal du dimanche
c'est pas parce que yves saint laurent
raccroche que la haute couture est morte
parce que je crois que c'est que c'est
vrai qu'avec saint orens comment une
époque de la haute couture est morte
parce que lui représente quand même tout
le passé la couture avec janet
dior balenciaga alors votre votre haute
couture et à l' équilibre financier
pratiquement maintenant où elle presque
c'est à dire que parce que sinon c'est
vrai qu'ils perdent et 70 millions par
an quand même hein vous devez dépenser
beaucoup plus bien alors dimanche
dernier donc j'ai vu le défilé couture
femmes
or très pipeau l'arrivée madonna elle
est un peu petit quand même aller ouais
mais aussi merveilleuse petite anna g
c'est-à-dire calais avec bolton sam est
bien proportionné je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous alors madonna elle
est venue le samedi en jet de londres en
jet privé el hafi copine qui s'appelle
green est gwyneth mais pas trop
donc elle vient avec sa copine gwyneth
elle passe la nuit au crillon et le
lendemain à cascastel va au défilé de
jean paul c'est sympa la vie quand c'est
comme ça
en plus vous étalez après déjeuner au
bazar tous les deux à ce que tous les
deux non il y avait d'autres personnes
en herbe
oui et c'est souvent comme ça parce que
ça il faut savoir quand même jean paul
c'est que me dit pas comment tu sais ça
parce que je veux c'est vous dites c'est
la seule femme avec laquelle j'aurais pu
faire l'amour et oui c'est un bon choix
non à part fait ça je n'ai aucune
française ne te fait franchir le
parnasse
je sais pas mais elle n'est pas non plus
américaine à les mélanger à les
italiennes
quand clavier comme ça
alors vous l'avez demandé jean paul
trois fois en mariage à chaque fois l'a
refusée poliment très poliment ah ouais
voilà ça n'a jamais marché entre lampaul
et madonna et maintenant elle est mariée
bah oui pas associé la can et costa y
porte une jupe ceci dit il a chéri
gauthier voilà voilà donc c'était très
polis mais madonna y avait bertrand
delanoë le maire de paris que je salue
ici bertrand puis assis à côté de
bertrand je lâche mon fier il ya madame
pompidou ça c'est incroyable même c'est
assez fou parce qu'elles continuent à
saint cyr alsa plein d'activités en
quarantaine alors les mannequins
évidemment c'est très classe chez
gaultier yves et naomi campbell y aller
inès de la fressange carla bruni dans
l'état sanchez une vieille copine à nous
et puis vous êtes pas faire maintenant
c'est un peu la mode d'éviter les top
modèles stars sur les podiums ou pas du
tout avait toujours cette fidélité comme
ça des stars et des passe-temps cergy
toujours pris à la fois bon certaine les
stars quand elle me convenait enfin
quand elle me convenait ces terres
qu'elle allait bien avec mes vêtements
ou alors des mannequins qui était pas du
tout mannequin vous avez fait défilé
jean-paul à l'époque et vigenal 80
tonnes que les pas de première jeunesse
loana steevy enfin voila vous vous
plaindrez sans jamais vraiment eu la
table mais donc j'ai eu un mannequin qui
avait 75 ans qui était génial une femme
vraiment qu'ils avaient toute sa vie
rêvé d'être mannequin le monde j'ai
passé neuf et dans les années 30 elle
devait rêver d'être mannequin et ses
parents l'avaient interdit elle a
réalisé son rêve à 75 ans et bien manger
bien non elle était super beau si c'est
ça c'est que c'est pas du tout alors on
peut avoir un âge certain
c'est vous avez eu des idées formidables
par jean kiffer les robes maintenant
c'est que les cravates en des cravates
que vous avez dû voir un jour dans une
droguerie en province parce que c'est
des cravates un sens et des cravates des
années 40
tout comme sept dans les friperies ou
des antiquaires je sais c'est des
cravates qui sont assemblés bord à bord
et ça fait des robes les deux violence
elle aussi c'est très très beau c'est à
dire qu'al des saveurs
c'est magnifique ça répond c'est un
petit peu quand même un modèle qui a
déjà été décolleté comme ça c'était
merida petit port était dans un film bon
mais l'annoncé il y avait déjà un
décolleté mais qui était retenu par une
chaîne lumière n'était pas retenue
seul par les fesses de faire la musique
est superbe il ya une robe qui est
génial c'est à dire complètement encore
un peu comme marilyn coiffure
complètement relevé devant commettre un
coup de vent comme exactement c'est
exactement l'idée c'est un fantôme
derrière c'est une robe normal comme si
le vent s'est relevé après avoir parlé
de l'avenir de la haute couture on va
parler maintenant du passé de jean paul
gaultier
[Applaudissements]
alors jean paul vous est né en 1952
arcueil
non je raconte en fait je vais raconter
l'enfance de jean paul gaultier parce
que vous n'avez jamais renier ni votre
enfant si votre classe sociale ni nous
amis de l'époque du collège dont vous
êtes quelqu'un de grande fidélité
alors parents modestes un père comptable
mère caissière au restaurant de la
caisse des dépôts et consignations c'est
vrai qu'il sait plein de détails ça il
malgré tout est alors éducation très
tolérante par exemple un jour il voit la
télévision devine qui vient dîner ce
soir avec sidney poitier qu est l
histoire d'un noir sidney poitier poser
une blanche à l'époque dans les années
60 et des années 50
je suis allé ce bloc est alors jeunes
soldats si vous dites à vos parents
ainsi j'épouse et une noire qu'est ce
que vous diriez ma mère m'a dit écoute
si tu les aimes pas parfait comme ça et
là jamais ce qu'il veut nous tuer fait
que te semble bien mais c'est fou parce
que voilà c'est pour l'époque et
pourtant là la classe sociale dans
laquelle vous étiez c'était quand même
très rare par exemple quand vos parents
vous leur dites que vous êtes homosexuel
bah si tu le lem il n'y a pas de
problème c'est pas grave ce soit un
garçon c'est à dire que des années après
elle a continué à avoir la même attitude
que voilà certains individus quand votre
grand mère vous a offert un livre sur
l'homosexualité
elle se douter de quelque chose passe
sur l'homosexualité est une histoire où
il y avait
quelque chose qui se passait comme ça
que je comprenais pas trop très bien si
vous avez des diamants est ce que terme
et les trois en un mot effectivement
[Rires]
c'est là non
c'est plus du tout passé 9 heures à 12
heures et tout elle m'a dit tu sais faut
être très gentil avec eux par la suite
je devenu très gentil très très très
gentil avec les militants n'en plaît pas
mais votre grand mère c'est comme
madonna vais aller les deux héroïnes de
votre vie
non un peu ouais c'est assez génial
parce qu'elle m'a donné confiance en moi
là bon si ça c'est à dire que je crois
que c'est assez génial quand même quand
on a la chance d'être aimée quand on est
gamin quoi ça sert à ça donne après une
espèce de force et de chiba c'est
merveilleux dans votre grand mère était
couturière elle était voyante à tirer
les cartes et donner des conseils de
beauté de relookage et vous essayez vos
talents de coloriste sur elle voilà j'ai
essayé comme sur mon tour c'est tout et
je lui teignant les cheveux quelques
fois en bleu acier mais je vais c'est
trop longtemps je faisais un un
défrisage en même temps du col de venir
aux voix des punks avant l'heure quoi
presque et c'est chez elle que vous
découvrez le corset et jean paul
gaultier une phrase sur le corps c'est
que je vais citer le corset c'est une
machinerie somme aux baleineaux aulas et
orthopédiques fascinant mais je trouve
que c'est une description du corps sec
et définitive
elle vous racontez votre grand mère
quand on mettait le corset canton effet
voilà c'est à dire que l avait pratiqué
elle-même le corse est destiné à
rétrécir la taille donc aussi à soutenir
quelque fois la colonne vertébrale est
enfin là sur un plan esthétique
donc elle prenait un verre de vinaigre
le buvaient et à ce moment là elle avait
une contraction quand ça rentrait donc
dans l'estomac et à ce moment là il
fallait serrer leur l'objet la taupe et
dick donc la taille après tu es tout
film c'est la dimension sado-maso où et
quand j'ai dû corser là quand même
totalement totalement le risque est
fascinante et alors 20 ans après vous
dessinez une europe qui est un corset
mais qui descend jusqu'à terre et dans
un sens il fallait être un petit peu en
effet sado maso pour le porter puisque
du fait qu'il était entièrement l'est
parce que je les fais vraiment comme un
vrai pur et dur donc je les fais jusqu'à
terre et là c'est jusqu'à terre
conclusion impossible de faire pipi
voilà donc la personne qui l'a portée et
qui commet elle est restée n'a
absolument rien bu rien fait et où elle
pouvait que bouger comme ça
difficilement puisque en plus était
entravé alors votre votre madeleine
c'est le parfum diriger la poudre de riz
de votre grand mère
l'honneur du châtelet enfin péter
baigner dans tout cet univers comme ça
des années quoi 50 64 est alors votre
grand mère vous dit tout ce que je fais
je le lui doit
si vous voulez comme à l'été avec ses
clientes et quelle est leur donner des
conseils et des conseils aussi bien vous
devriez peut-être changer de coiffure
alors tiré les cas vous devriez changer
de coiffure comme ça vous ne seriez
mieux avec votre mari donc moi je
prenais comment je voyais en fin de
compte l'importance de la lure par
rapport à ce que ça pouvait avoir comme
conséquences sur la vue donc
l'importance du paraître
alors autres influences évidemment dim
dam dom l'émission de daisy de galard
l'extraordinaire et émission qui n'est
jamais été égalé par la suite d'un sur
les émissions aussi sur la haute couture
de jean christophe averty enfin c'est
l'époque où la télé aurait pu devenir un
art c'est il y aurait eu des télés ascom
ya des cinéastes mais malheureusement la
télé est ce que ça voulait dire
exactement dim dam dom mid mad mode
dimanche à la mine mana c'est déjà du
verlan à voter influencé aussi par la
presse l'écho de la moe le jardin des
modes elle influencé par les folies
bergères aussi sa cause était petit
découpez des plumeaux voilà pour en
faire une revue se dire que c'était mon
os qui devenait la line renaud la mick
micheyl et faisait la revue à ma grand
mère cet ours en peluche
vous lui avez fait des faux seins déjà
voilà les premiers avant madonna
ouais c'est à dire les c'était des cônes
déconne déjà en papier journal et voilà
et je lui ai parlé je faisais aussi
subir tous les sévices de l'époque
s'appelait nana normal pour un ours
bah oui c'est ça si vous êtes joli
dessin d'ailleurs parce que je ne voyais
pas à l'époque ne visaient pas les
hommes mais c'est cette source il est
toujours dans votre bureau dans une
boîte à ces sermons et puis alors aussi
de votre vos influences c'est aussi
paris ou venus en deux chevaux le samedi
après midi puis le paris des touristes
japonais quoi le paris des cartes
postales
j'adore ouais c'est ça à 18 ans vont
rentrer chez cardin comme assistant
votre mère vous accompagne moi parce que
j'étais trop timide c'est le jour de mon
anniversaire à me dis tiens cardin tu
attends je vais pas y aller tout seul
donc elle est là et puis jouer monsieur
cardin qui m'engagent tout de suite que
ça c'est assez génial parce que le fait
qu'il engage sans que j'aie fait aucune
école de mode
ça prouve à face à maoulida quand même
un petit peu l'esprit
et là jean paul gaultier commence à
mélanger à métisser avec une approche un
peu on pourrait dire de stylistes
puisque de ça c'est grâce aux
journalistes en fin de mois parce que
quand j'étais petit donc comme je n'ai
pas fait d'école de main je regardais et
je lisais sur tout ce qu'ils écrivaient
les journalistes et quelquefois le
montrait ben oui ce vêtement là vous
pouvez le porter de telle ou telle façon
mélangés par exemple une combinaison de
mécano avec des talons aiguille les des
bijoux en strass et je trouvais ça aussi
intéressant qu'en fin de compte que les
créations de couturiers
je trouvais aussi intéressante mais ça
aussi ça me trouvais ça parce que mieux
ce qui est extraordinaire avec vautier
c'est que maintenant quand tu vois dans
la rue une fille qui a un blouson de
cuir un tut tut danseuses et des tennis
bat c'est lui messi c'est pourtant
aujourd'hui c'est devenu quelque chose
de très très courant c'est pas toujours
lui un des fois c'est déjà exceptionnel
c'est tranquillisant aussi voir ce qu'on
peut dire ce qu'on peut dire pour
résumer le travail de jean paul gaultier
si vous avez fait avec la meute ce
qu'ont fait les musiciens que sampling
ça mais ça n'est pas que ça veux qu'ils
se connectent et jean paul lafay aussi
la musique on peut le dossier vous allez
avoir droit à une hardy view
starmania
tu bouges par le jingle ce qu'on pourait
rallumer s'il vous plaît pas je sais
qu'il ya des gens qui bougent le c
j'y vois la chapelle jean paul gaultier
on va faire une hardy view
ou pas
je ne bouge pas pendant le général cône
a enchanté moi c'est l'horreur
alors jean paul gaultier on se concentre
vous pensez à quoi là maintenant
présentement à la question que vous êtes
en train de poser voilà quand vous
regardez la glace le matin vous dites
quoi t'as d'beaux yeux tu sais ce que je
me dis ouais quand vous étiez petit vous
lire semblait acquis à saturne savez le
canard le petit canard et tous explique
ici comment s'explique ce à tout est
clair ce soir
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois et beau défilé de saint-laurent
justement quel est le péché qui vous
tente le plus la gourmandise
que pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif
sur vous non merci
si votre vie était à refaire que
changeriez vous rien qui avez vous le
plus envie d'épater madame pompidou
oui on va dire que c'est moi même quand
téléphone sonne les heureux ou agacé ben
ça dépend ça dépend si c'est ça dépend
si c'est le téléphone privé ou du coeur
ou comme ça la ligne ce que tout le
monde appelle les livreurs et oui
jennifer
robin s'inscrit et vous devrez vous
donnerez sans les visiteurs
c'est génial que feriez vous s'il vous
restait 24 heures à vivre je ferai une
orgie de bouffe et du sexe allait bien
il vous reste
quel est le surnom qu'on vous donne que
vous haïssez l'enfant terrible de la
mode sont maintenant comment voir est un
peu vieilli l'enfant terrible vous êtes
resté quand même dans ces régions est
resté très moment quand même non
mentalement prêt mentalement et dieu
dans tout ça que son coin c'est vrai ces
machins ses chances est ce pour ça bah
le dieu il faut qu'ils s'habillent coutu
non non vous êtes marrant parce qu'on
fait du sampling même pour la religion
puisque vous religion était très sain
critiques c'est à dire vous dites on
prendra un petit peu chez le cateau un
petit peu chez les juifs
un choix qui est plein de choses
toutes les religions est-ce que vous
organisez rien d'inné où l'on ne parle
pas de vous bah oui comme ça je pourrai
manger
qu'avez-vous fait que nous ne sachions
pas j'aime bien faire quelquefois les
entrées dans les hôtels par exemple vous
savez il ya toujours les cartes là de
petits déjeuners et tout alors j'aime
bien changer leurs mets toi plutôt genre
4 heures du matin avec des énormes du
nord du gard des harengs de changer
songez vous changer les choses si rossi
il reste aux talons aiguilles et là où
on sait qu'il ya un monsieur ou
d'auxerre fabre voilà qu'est ce que vous
avez dans vos poches la préservatif de
quelques questions à me riez vous avoir
la réponse
dieu existe-t-il miroir mon beau miroir
qui est la plus belle à billets et ce
soir dakar qu'est ce que la vie vous a
appris qu'on pouvait faire ce qu'on rêve
si on est passionné voilà donc faire
tout ce qu'on rêve est encore tombé
ouais avez vous une meilleure opinion de
vous aujourd'hui qu'à 20 ans
moi je me sens mieux dans ma peau nous
as oui à quels signes reconnaissez-vous
infailliblement la bêtise c'est
difficile à dire parce que moi j'en dis
pas mal de sottises m'enfin je sais pas
ce qui me ferait un peu c'est les gens
qui sont très sûrs d'eux et qu'ils
croient connaître la réponse à tous
merci
une autre étude diam's et pas toutes les
réponses que quel est votre expression
favorite vin vieux amants ouais c'est un
génie ou venez vous proposez d'exaucer
un de vos souhaits quel souhait vous
feriez ce serait de ressusciter des
personnes qui sont mortes et que j'aime
voilà quelle est l'insulté qui vous a
fait le plus mal [ __ ] et maintenant
[Musique]
soit
bah si ciani marchal et jean paul
gaultier
[Musique]
oh
ce climat
jean paul gaultier les bons soit 1100
j'en passe alors tony vous êtes une
enfant de la balle
puisque vous êtes la fille de bill
marchal acteur réalisateur américain le
mari de mme michèle morgan à une époque
est donc le grand père de la fameuse
sarah marshall et oui deux parentes un
petit peu que ça marche c'est ma nièce
ses motifs voilà je la connais très peu
mais on s'est vus
il ya assez longtemps avant qu'elle
épouse j'ai oublié son nom alex ans
alexandre anthony voilà il faut un beau
couple tous les deux mais il paraît d'un
voleur est la fille donc de bill
marshall et de micheline presle
ah ben c'est évidemment de cette grande
actrice considérer qu'on adore tous
micheline presle voilà et quand vous
étiez enfant vous dormiez dans une
chambre qui jouxtait la salle de
projection du studio des ursulines
alors quand il était tout petit
l'entendiez leçon et puis ensuite c'est
devenu copine avec l'ouvreuse et puis
elle vous laisser rentrer dans la salle
du studio des ursulines
comme ça vous avez vu très jeunes des
films de godard de bergman les einstein
enfin vraiment vous avez une formation
très précoce javel à la cabine du
projectionniste était à peu près on
était séparés par une cour de trois
mètres et donc l'été particulièrement il
aller fumer une clope sur le l'escalier
en métal et donc il ouvrait la porte de
la cabine et j'ai donc ce que j'ai pu
j'ai connu les films en entier par le
son je connais alexandre nevsky
pratiquement phonétiquement etc voilà
alors vous avez fait plein de films vous
à votre tour ensuite le plus connu
disons c'est vénus beauté institut qui a
été nominé sept fois aux césar qui avait
décroché quatre césar du meilleur film
du meilleur scénario de la meilleure
réalisatrice et meilleur espoir féminin
pour la fameuse audrey tautou tout qui
depuis a fait jusqu'à la floride
si audrey tautou
non peut-être que tu la connais mieux
sous le nom de
catherine dit amélie poulain de labeur
et votre dernier film j'étais france
boutiques dont judith godrèche c'est
venu parler ici cette idée voilà alors
jean paul gaultier vous en plus des
activités qui porte votre nom va pas
toutes les énumérer parce que ça
commence à faire pas mal
vous avez signé en mars dernier votre
première collection pour hermès ou vous
revisiter les grands classiques de la
maison dans un esprit
voilà moderniser gauthier voilà ludique
vous continuez à travailler pour le
cinéma et le spectacle vous êtes occupé
de peter greenaway de caro et jeunet de
besson d'almodovar de madonna d'yvette
horner de johnny hallyday et de sylvie
vartan
alors j'ai lu dans une interview j'ai lu
dans une interview récemment tejada
sylvie vartan les autres j'étais content
mais l appel à frais contente dans son
bouquin ça donc on a lu le bouquin de
sylvie vartan et à aucun moment elle se
plaint de vous alors la seule chose qui
aurait pu arriver c'est qu'elle oublie
de parler de vous mais elle ne dit pas
de mal de vous dans son bouquin alors je
sais pas je me demande je me demande si
en fin de compte j'ai pas lu un autre
livre art et ouais parce que je sais pas
il y en a pas deux sur sylvie vartan
celui là il est écrit par elle dans
celui qui est écrit par elle ne parle
pas de vous du tout alors ça doit être
l'hôte écrit par un journaliste suite
que j'ai lu et je crois excepté celui un
ou une ville et une couverture 4g en
couverture voilà c'est pas elle on a
beau chercher elle dit rien contre vous
et l'eau mais simplement de bars et de
goût c'est vrai
[Musique]
alors justement si vous deviez relooké
vincent peillon quand même à l'homme
politique
pourquoi qu'est bulku plutôt beau gosse
faut dire les choses 1 qui était
intelligent travailleur tout mais au
niveau du look est ce que vous pensez
qu'il doit rester comme ça pour pour
faire sérieux pour faire hommes
politiques la cravate le costume ça pour
être très honnête ça me fascine pas
tellement le fait d' habiller comment
les politiciens parce que je trouve que
bon ils ont certaines règles à appliquer
tout bon bah voilà un délai à quoi les
jeunes super classer le mieux non pour
eux habillés un animateur télé ça vous
centrez jean-paul moi par exemple la
rentrée qu'est ce que vous me
conseilleriez parce que ça fait quand
même à damien 18 ans je suis habillée
comme ça va bien comme sa robe se
trouvent c'est comme une espèce d'image
de marque regardez n'a réussi jean paul
gaultier ce que vous faites des fautes
de goût moi sûrement plein on s'est déjà
retrouvé en train de faire des courses
le dimanche matin avec un survêt et des
mocassins vous est arrivé ça ce genre de
qui peut devenir bien ceci bien mais qui
peut devenir bien ça dépend comme tout
est fait de la façon dont s'est fait
quoi il ya des choses qui sont à une
époque horrible c'est tout ce qu'il faut
pas faire puis après qu'il ait au
contraire qu'on trouve on passe super un
stade différent et on trouve ça plutôt
rigolo et bien vous êtes déjà retrouvé
en mars elle devant un match de foot par
exemple
ben non je regarde pas et ouais je foute
alors déjà à l'église en minijupe et
dominator j'ai jamais allé je porte pas
une jupe l'équipe je le porte de temps à
autre mais
les guides mais rarement demain jusqu'à
demain après midi sur france 5
absolument absolument je ne sais pas un
match de foot non non à 15h30 sur france
5 il ya un documentaire de tonie
marshall sur jean paul gaultier voilà
alors au début quand on vous a dit de
faire un documentaire vous vous êtes dit
oui l'a jamais fait le documentaire
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
et puis
vous pareil vous dites oh là là je vais
pas voir une équipe sur le dos pendant
cinq mois donc au départ c'était pas
c'était pas évident savait pas encore
que celle est tonie marshall
quand j'ai su que c'était elle et ce qui
nous réunit c'est un film un film sur la
mode un film des années 50 un film de
jacques becker qui s'appelle falbala
dont l'héroïne est votre maman micheline
presle et il se trouve que micheline
presle vous vous l'adorez dervout
l'avait habillée pour le propos les
césar on voit ça la fin du documentaire
d'ailleurs mais oui tout à fait puisque
bon moi je suis un enfant de la télé on
va dire donc gg je regardais la télé
tuant tout gamin et je me souviens qu'il
ya un moment j'avais vu l'émission des
folies bergères sur les folies bergères
je voulais à billets je voulais faire
des costumes pour les folies bergères ça
a commencé comme ça et puis après j'ai
vu falbala et là ça a été le coup de
foudre totale je dis non c'est la mode
moi ça je vous devais avoir j'ai pas 12
ans 10 12 ans et c'est quand même
probablement le seul film qui raconte le
processus d'une collection de haute
couture du début jusqu'à la fin se dire
qu'après ça c'était la vérité c'était ma
bible en quelques secondes
voilà un certain jacques becker très
beau film alors le documentaire
s'appelle les falbalas de jean paul
gaultier est pas pour rien
donc vous parler de votre vie
professionnelle et puis de votre vie
privée alors son plan professionnel
on apprend que vous dessinez deux
collections par an dont vous êtes
toujours dans l'urgence quoi c'est ouais
ouais c'est un petit peu c'est ça le
rythme de la mode c'est c'est assez
étonnant en plus on peut faire
quelquefois des collections qui sont
plusieurs saisons en même temps enfin la
cheville est à la fois sur l'été et
l'hiver enfin alors découvre aussi dans
ce documentaire que vous laisser appeler
monsieur comme coco chanel c'est appeler
mademoiselle jusqu'à présent que disait
jean-paul ou bon d'abord parce qu'on
n'était pas nombreux et puis j'ai
commencé par des affaires du
prêt-à-porter
ce n'était pas la même façon là même le
même vocabulaire on va dire que dans la
couture où j'ai commencé et en insistant
mais là comme j'ai pris certaines
personnes certains comment met-on la
première d'atelier qui venait de la
couture elle avait l'habitude de dire
monsieur pascal travailler avec monsieur
givenchy donc ça a été monsieur donc je
me suis retrouvée d'un seul coup paf
avec monsieur ouais ça va un peu chanel
qua non sauf que c'était ma demoiselle
dont elle m'a pas dit mademoiselle sera
peut-être un peu plus étonné
mademoiselle s'est alors emparé de votre
vie privée aussi d'une façon assez
franche du trou un voyage pour assister
non c'est vrai c'était c'est ouais ouais
ouais je vais cas ce documentaire vous
avez évité une psychanalyse sûrement
mais oui c'est ça ce que je disais en
fin de compte j'ai merci thani alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous l'avez
eue là pendant cinq mois c'est
absolument étonnant c'est à dire que je
crois qu'il parle il un espèce de on va
dire quoi un espèce de petit cimetière
de bouts de tissus de plume une vieille
santiag de l'état tout comme ça alors il
va derrière il tripote des tas de
morceaux comme ça il tripote énormément
il a absolument besoin de ça il a pas de
dessin il a vaguement des trucs collé au
mur qui regarde pas souvent
et puis tripote il tripote il tripote et
après il commence à avoir une toile
et puis voilà s'il ya des choses en jour
on le voit dans le documentaire ya des
moments où il ça rate complètement oui
cela etc
et puis tout d'un coup ça vient et là
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que on
voit qu est ce que c'est qu'un moment où
tu vois là parce que jean-paul il ne
crée le vêtement que par la parole il
n'arrête pas de parler pour le riz dit
tout le temps tout le temps alors là le
titre on t'a fait si ça fait ça puis au
bout d'un moment ils arrêtent de dire le
tissu il commence à dire alors là je
vais avoir ça un peu plus serré dit dont
l'âge clock
et puis alors là je god donc je vais
rebond alors il faut me faut je ne suis
pas doubler et il se met absolument à la
place du vêtement et à partir de là le
discours structure alors qu'avant je
viens de vêtements mais il devient le
vêtement et ses travaux et sa ya peu
après il perfectionne les cinglés quoi
moyens cintrée
inventer la jupe aux roms et
dernièrement le maquillage pour hommes
testés par vincent perez josé garcia
david beckham non il ya des choses c'est
à la fois comment la frette tonifiant
enfin merci d une tonique et puis aussi
les choses par exemple pour les lèvres
pour se protéger les led mais en même
temps que leur est un peu si on veut
mais ça peut être aussi très neutre à la
base et aussi pour je n'ai pas les
sourcils ou comme comme le col des
touareg et touareg
c'est un tour des yeux bon donc c'est
des choses quand même
on peut très bien les maîtres sans avoir
l'air maquillé gamme pour hommes
politiques mais je crois qu'il est
neutre et alors on se passe avec un
blaireau sait à quels sont les gestes
par exemple même pour le comme un stylo
voilà si l'eau parce que c'est un geste
que un geste de plus voilà quel peut
être l'avenir de la mode
on va faire une interview à la mode
[Musique]
est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour
pourrait être à la mode
les espadrilles montante ah oui tout à
fait les pantalons dans les chaussettes
totalement c'est pas beau quand même les
portails wilson tout va à lambert wilson
même son nom non mais sérieux y mettrait
le pantalon et chaussures très beau
gosse les soutiens gorge pour hommes
saluerait non mais c'est à laval près
c'est vrai c'est que tout va alors lui
c'est la justice c'est comme ça que les
gens fassent des gants le soutien gorge
il peut avoir des dd défendent 6,6 et
dessine la morphologie masculine peut
être musclé mais oui à partir du moment
où il ya un record
c'est pas comme une prothèse quoi pour
un string kangourou le défendrai bien
peut-être c'est déjà la mode y en a
certains qui le le tombeau de [ __ ] dans
une peau de bits
je veux dire pour pouvoir la [ __ ] s'est
lui dit alors c'est comme les manteaux
de patchwork fois ci c'est une pièce
c'est joli quand même je me semble
possible pourquoi pas non les belles
choses qui sont faites comme ça y allait
y a des il ya des dépôts de poissons et
tous qui sont incroyables pour que les
blancs il ya plein de choses qui sont
faites donc la peau de bits peut en
effet être un élément pourquoi pas tant
qu'on fera pas les mercis c'est pourquoi
est ce qu'il en reste est assez saine
car des mecs jean paul gaultier il ya
aussi un âge où amélie t.blx à la
fondation cartier sur vague couture by
jean paul vettier
[Musique]